well this to me means all things in
balance and balance doesn't mean all
things are equal or at peace at all time
ouch yeah on Saturday Oprah took a
tumble on stage at the LA stop of her
20/20 vision tour 4ww look at this Oh
wasn't fazed by the onstage
oops everybody in the lines could see it
were you thinking oh my god this is
embarrassing to be thinking I'm just
gonna roll with it and anything
embarrassing I understand okay I felt
everybody knows what falling is you
would prefer not to go oh yeah but now I
fall in my most my thing was I'm falling
I can't get up okay as if Oprah couldn't
get any better
she also handles a fall like no one else
I thought this was a great day in spite
of the fall which now becomes a meme I
know but I picked myself up I don't know
if it was something on the floor or like
foot twisted or wet
the indication I was gonna fall before
and then you know it just is what it is
it was a great great date yeah Oprah
didn't let the slip-up trip up her day
at all
Ellie knows all the stuff Ellie knows
Eckhart Tolle
Ellie goes la is this is the only time
when we were doing the quiet meditation
but what he says everybody read out
there was a because people know how to
breathe in LA yes we do
[Music]
anyways post-fall overpowered through
the rest of the inspiring event bringing
Jennifer Lopez out for a one-on-one chat
about life love and yes even looks are
there some days where you look at
yourself and you go
[Applause]
you know what's really hard days were
you saying okay no there are days yeah
where I'll look in the mirror like I'm
getting out of the shower and I'm
looking at myself just glory and I'm
like well you sexy yeah okay thank you
for admitting that Jennifer Lopez thank
you but back to Oprah on Sunday she
shared this shot Ising her knee after
the fall captioning the pic quote yes I
slipped on stage and I'm now a meme but
so grateful to be only a little sore
turning the day into what Michelle Obama
calls hashtag self-care Sunday can Oprah
get any better
seriously can she oh my all right guys
stick with you tea for all the latest on
lady oh and the rest of her vision to
our hopefully no more false balance
doesn't mean all things are equal or at
peace at all times
cute that'll do it for now until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]